un lápiz gigante junto a su ya
reconocible sombrero los dos símbolos de
pedro castillo profesor de izquierdas
que fue el más votado en la primera
vuelta de las elecciones en perú ahora
por un estrecho margen lidera las
encuestas para la segunda vuelta un
hecho impensable hasta hace apenas dos
meses cuando castillo ni siquiera era
tenido en cuenta entre los favoritos su
gran propuesta es el cambio
constitucional para destinar el 10% del
pib ea salud y educación
discurso en favor de los más
desfavorecidos que acabó por convencer
el pasado 11 de abril al 19 por ciento
de los electores y les importa un pepino
cuando ve que el hombre y la mujer en el
pueblo mueren clamando justicia castillo
se dio a conocer por primera vez durante
la huelga de profesores de 2017 ahora se
ha convertido en una figura
controvertida en perú su perfil
marcadamente izquierdista levanta
pasiones entre muchos especialmente
entre la gente del campo desde la
derecha en cambio han tratado de
asociarse con cuba o venezuela plan
bueno comentó disyuntiva de un lado y
que no deba hacer venezuela-cuba
norcorea de lo peor también con sendero
luminoso y la violencia política del
pasado tras el asesinato de 16 personas
supuestamente a manos de remanentes de
este grupo el pasado 24 de mayo en una
zona remota del país
que refugiamos abiertamente no solamente
atenderlos sino ante el mundo a estos
pensamos en sendero luminoso y también
[Música]
en el campo progresista la figura de
castillo también es polémica
está en contra del aborto y del
matrimonio igualitario también rechaza
la eutanasia y el enfoque de género en
las escuelas un perfil izquierdista en
lo económico y más conservador en lo
social